voici la rue au coeur de la polémique
fin janvier plusieurs riverains qui
avaient garé leur voiture dans cette
avenue ont découvert une contravention
de 135 euros sur leur pare-brise donc la
fameuse petite contraventions qui
indique pas du tout pourquoi comment la
date l'heure au début de l'année la voie
était en sens unique mais en raison des
travaux qui ont pris de l'ampleur dans
le quartier renard la municipalité a
décidé de passer la ksa double sens et
d'interdire le stationnement hors des
emplacements matérialisés
la raison qui nous est donné c'est oui
il faut que les engins peas ont circulé
dans cette avenue
mais ce soit à double sens où que ce
soit à sens unique qu'on soit garée d'un
côté ça ne change rien c'est à dire
qu'il ya toujours la même place pour que
les camions passent comme nous avons des
personnes âgées qui viennent parce que
je suis retraité et qu'ils n'ont pas de
classe dans la rue et bien plutôt que
d'aller très très loin il préfère s'en
aller carrément ils nous préviennent
qu'ils ne viendront pas ce genre là quoi
pointant le manque de place dans le
quartier les riverains demandent au
maire de les autoriser à pouvoir
stationner de nouveau dans cette avenue
réponse de l'intéressé de nombreuses
places payantes dans le parking
souterrain de la résidence sont
disponibles la ville a exigé dès le
départ de la part des constructeurs qui
est 25 à 30 % de places de plus que le
nombre de logements
malheureusement aujourd'hui des gens qui
ont des voitures dans les villes
le bio y aura toujours un problème de
stationnement parce qu'en surface
on ne pourra pas avoir autant de places
qui lie à bois tueur autre requête du
collectif de riverains une place pour
les personnes handicapées la mairie
répond qu'il suffit d'en faire
simplement la demande